thor love and thunder has double the
thor action with jane foster joining
odin's son but for many fans the real
star of the show is the man who's trying
to burn it all down warning spoilers for
thor love and thunder ahead
in marvel movies the hero is typically
only as good as the villain they have to
go up against and in thor love and
thunder we see the god of thunder battle
one of his most imposing foes to date in
the past thor's biggest battles have
often been family affairs with the
exception of molokith the dark elf and
thanos the mad titan thor has spent most
of his time battling his siblings namely
loki and hella they even had his issues
with his father before he grew up a
little and proved himself to be worthy
but now he needs some fresh blood to go
up against and he gets it in the form of
gore the godbutcher gore's issue with
thor is fairly straightforward he felt
betrayed by his own god so once he got
hold of the necrosword he vowed to kill
every god out there
thor is no exception and based on some
of the scenes we get he's pretty
efficient in his god killing
he manages to defeat some truly
formidable foes before turning his
attention to eternity and getting that
coveted wish to take out every god once
and for all he may be the bad guy but
he's more than made his mark on fans who
can't help but praise what's arguably
one of the best villains in a marvel
movie ever
thor love and thunder opens with a
sequence showing gore's tragic backstory
as he wanders the desert with his
daughter doomed to die when he finally
stumbles upon his god he's heartbroken
to realize that the god doesn't care
about him or his dead daughter in
response he vows to kill every god out
there for revenge it's a heartbreaking
sequence who can't empathize with a man
who's just lost his daughter and fans
seem to think this makes gore one of the
better antagonists to come out of marvel
studios one redditor kicked off a
discussion on the topic saying this was
the first time in a very long time that
i actually felt the menace of the
villain and jeopardy of the characters
and it was the first time i felt that i
wanted to see more of the villain's
adventures a ton of people agreed with
many wishing they had gotten to see more
of gore in the flick one user stated
definitely wish we could have seen at
least one more scene of god butchery
there may very well be more gore moments
on the horizon somewhere in the special
features of the movie's home release in
an interview with ign bale mentioned how
one particular scene had to be left on
the cutting room floor potentially for
being a little bit too extreme so anyone
hoping for more god butchery may well
get their wish granted in the months to
come i'm counting on that
gore likely won't come back to the mcu
anytime soon for another adventure
considering the film's ending but
deleted scenes would be more than
welcome if it means fans can spend a
little bit more time with a surprisingly
compelling god butcher in thor love and
thunder gora's health gradually
deteriorates due to his use of the
necrosword by the time he reaches
eternity he's nearly at death's door and
with his final promised wish he brings
his daughter back to life at the end of
the day gore is really just a family man
he just wanted his family to be safe
which is par the course for the gore
readers know from the comics gore's
comic origin story is similar to the one
we see in the film while he initially
believes in the worthiness of the gods
he soon loses hope due to the loss of
his wife and children unlike the film
his final child is a boy in the comics
but his faith isn't enough and his child
quickly perishes
gore is a relatively new addition to
comic's lore he made his first
appearance in thor god of thunder number
two in 2012 and he's gone on to have
numerous spars with the likes of the
asgardian for those wishing for more
adventures with gore the pages of a
comic will be your best bet there are
plenty of folks who would like to see
more of the antagonist as evidenced by
one redditor who wrote honestly i could
watch a gore movie just the opening with
his daughter made me sympathize with him
such an interesting character gore's
return to the mcu is unlikely despite
characters having come back from the
dead before but if you want more gore
you'll have to head over to your local
comic shop
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you